there's marcus right there towing the
slab gear and the only hit off him was
aquino in that one hitter over eight
innings he's two-and-oh lifetime and
three starts against the reds the 1.93
earned run average
hit two home runs on friday but he
strikes out of the slider by stroman to
start this game and so strowman picks up
where he left off in his last start
against the reds
and weaker grounds went into the shift
that's marcus's game getting the ground
ball mcneal throws out winker two away
heart lead for an extra bullpen arm
farmer lines one toward the middle one
hopper for mcneal
and that retires the side strong first
inning for marcus strowman nine pitches
three outs mets come to bat no score
the vladimir gutierrez coming off a
strong showing against the cubs his
numbers from western and southern i
really think that the outing that he had
against the cubs was better than his
line score you know he went six in a
third of two-run baseball but those two
runs came in the first inning on a home
run by
anthony rizzo and then he threw shutout
ball ever since then so i think he's on
back where he belongs i think that you
know it's a learning process you're
working your way through the major
leagues the very first time and you've
got a lot of things to adjust to no
decision
and he sticks the fastball lower third
and mcneil goes down looking let's
catcher stevenson and the 3-1 pitch
alonzo swing sends a high fly ball to
left but winker will move back and make
the catch as he drifts toward the line
and pete alonso is the second out in the
first ninth inning two ounce two strikes
he tied the game
this one to right center
naquin
on the warning track
fairly pitch efficient one two three
first for gutierrez
it's a double play ball but who's going
to cover second nobody and that's merely
the second out
baez tried to hustle over behind mcneil
to get to the bag
but not sure if they could have made the
play there
and mcneil talk it over after the play
is over there's nothing they could do
there actually was pretty good heads up
heads up on abayas he's very alert look
how far left baez is he's not gonna get
to second base in time but he tried he
did sprinted right for the bag to see if
mcneal maybe could get it to him there
now the pitch
swing on a high fly ball to left center
pallard drifting back into the gap calls
off smith makes the one hand catch side
retired and again it looked like naquin
went down and was out in front just a
bit of that same pitch the split
and the reds are done in the second no
runs ahead one left middle of the second
inning it's the reds nothing the mets
nothing
gets into that pitch to center field a
spun around pilar doesn't have a good
read it's over his head it dies at the
base of the wall and india up to second
base a standing double
and now here's jesse winker who rounded
out his first time up he over the knob
of the bat
fling and a miss he struck him out with
a high fastball
so strowman after a couple of sliders
goes upstairs to get winker for his
second strike out of the day leaving
india stranded
on to the bottom of the third no score
how farmer hits one to shallow center
back goes mcneal reaching and he makes
the catch beautiful play
that ball did not have a lot of air
under it and mcneil really hustled to
get out there
and make that catch to retire farmers
well the key to this is you're like a
wide receiver and you're running a long
bomb and just keep don't pull up
keep running
and this is just a real nice play by
jeff
back shock bats he has one of the reds
two hits today
max schrock to right field that's
trouble
gone
home run max schrock
and the reds lead one nothing
and this even better i mean he gets one
right down the
pipe and he knocks it out of here
so two straight
ropes against strowman
two out home run by schrock in the
following hit by suarez
and now tyler naked
and that's lined to the left center of
base hit for naiquin
suarez around second on his way to third
dug out by pilar and they're going to
wave suarez home here comes the flow by
bias to the plate
by neato he's out
javi baez with the great relay after
pillar dug it off the wall and suarez is
gunned down trying to score from first
on a double
they just added one of the best
defensive players in baseball and
he just made a terrific throw home
vladimir gutierrez has been outstanding
he has retired seven straight 12 of 13.
strike three oh gutierrez with perhaps
his most dominant ap of the day
oh two
swing and a miss back-to-back case oh
gutierrez has been great on the day but
he's filthy in the fifth
ground is past the slide of suarez
first hit of the game against gutierrez
neato to the leaping farmer on a hop he
secures it
we are through five
a one hitter in progress for gutierrez
something off speed down there different
story
and that's a fair ball past the dive of
alonso kicks off the side wall winker
storms up to second throws from right
head first slide and a hustle double
that he threads inside of first
both of farmers outs have gone to second
a grounder to mcneil a pop to mcneil
farmer rips that one well struck to
center headlock dive misses the ball all
the way to the wall winker given the
wave he rips through third former
through second weaker comes home the
throw to third ahead first line
and rbi triple from kyle farmer
and the reds lead to zip with a man 90
feet away and nobody out
stevenson opposite way that's plenty
deep conforto
makes the catch tag in third conforto
comes up firing farmer to the plate safe
slide sec fly rbi
stevenson delivers a three-run reds lead
miguel castro in to get one key out
and he walked him on four pitches
can you believe that
miguel castro walks the pitcher on four
pitches vladimir guerreros has his first
major league rbi
as schrock trots home with the third run
of the inning and it's four nothing red
and that will bring up jeff mcneal if
you have to sift through pitch to mcneal
hit in the air pretty deep to right
center nequin going back to the track
he's at the wall and it's gone a home
run
jeff mcneal
with his sixth home run of the year gets
the mets on the board here in the sixth
inning the reds lead is cut to four to
one
max schrock his first career four hit
game in the biggs
truck
gets by
mack truck is five for five
green light and farmer shoots home the
reds expand the lead it's 5-1 on a
five-hit day for max rock wow
naked right field that is down he's
blown the game wide open stevenson
scores
truck scores
a two run double for naquin
another three spot for the reds a 7-1
lead in the night
that's what started the road trip
to right center
that's how it ends with a baez fly out
and the reds romp in the finale they
take the series their first series win
at citi field since may of 2013
blowing out the mets 7-1